in the 11th century the palace of  westminster was originally home to the  country's kings and queens 200 years  later it became the meeting place of the  parliament of england destroyed by fire  in 1834 the palace was rebuilt but no  significant refurbishment has taken  place since then now the gothic  splendors of its cast iron roof is  leaking the limestone walls are  crumbling away and the building is  riddled with asbestos  while a 50 million pounds a year program  keeps the palace in operation it's  thought a full refurbishment would cost  in the region of three billion pounds a  full report recommending what work  should be done is due this summer  what is clear is that any renovations  will need to be carried out soon before  the lights are turned out in the iconic  building